[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein schnelles pasta
rezepte ich weiß morath wird nicht so
ganz glücklich darüber sein denn ich
mache ein paar stars mit kürbis aber ich
habe euch gefragt bei instagram absage
wollt ihr rezept damit gewiss ja oder
nein und viele haben gesagt hier
und deswegen gibt es heute ein kürbis
rezept mit vollkornnudeln und ich mach
dazu noch shrimps also tiger garnelen
habe ich jetzt hier teige kanälen black
tiger garnelen und es ist auch
tatsächlich eine premiere auf einem
kanal denn ich habe es eigentlich nicht
so ganz mit meeresfrüchten
allerdings fand ich sie hier drin
richtig lecker denn wir haben das
gericht schon mal in österreich gegessen
bei einem guten freund dessen frau dass
wir uns gekocht hat ich weiß nicht genau
wie sie es gemacht hat aber ich denke so
wie ich jetzt gleich machen werde hoffe
ich hoffe es wird mir genauso gut
gelingen wie bei euch und ihr könnt das
ganze natürlich auch gerne ohne garnelen
zu bereiten dann ist es sogar vegan und
vegetarisch so ist so und ich zeige euch
jetzt mal was sich an zutaten dafür
brauche ich habe jetzt hier auch schon
salat
da habe ich blut am basar am war
bisschen knoblauch knobloch und
schnittlauch aus dem garten und tomaten
gibt es dann gleich einfach dazu sie
habe ich schon die tiger garnelen diesen
aus dem tiefkühlfach und die habe ich
jetzt bereits geschält und damit sind
sie nämlich schon dann brauche ich
zwiebeln und knoblauch 10
ich habe hier etwas olivenöl allen
hokkaido kürbis salbei aus dem garten
salz und pfeffer ich habe ich noch
vollkorn passt da ich nehme jetzt hier
spaghetti kürbiskerne und auch
getrocknete tomaten dieselöl gelegt die
getrockneten tomaten die haben übrigens
auch selber gemacht also das waren
unsere cocktailtomaten die habe ich
gedauert und dann mit knoblauch und
kräutern einfach in öl eingelegt und
jetzt fange ich direkt mal an mit dem
kürbis zuerst einmal ich habe jetzt hier
nun hokkaido das ist eigentlich auch so
der gängigste kürbis muss man dazu sagen
und bei dem ist der vorteil dass er ihn
nicht schälen müsst ich halt wir denn
jetzt
wir müssen aber aufpassen dass er nicht
abrutscht mit dem messer kurz den boden
weg und das da oben weg die kerne könnt
ihr tatsächlich aufheben und essen kann
man nämlich schon auswaschen und dann
rösten und dann habt ihr kürbis gerne
und ich schneide jetzt hier einfach
schön in spalten
ihr könnt den aber auch fein würfeln
wenn ihr möchtet
ich finde jetzt noch spalten irgendwie
schöner haufen teiler
das ist echt jetzt nur noch optisch
entscheidung kann ich hier schon mal das
olivenöl erhitzen auf mittel hoher stufe
ungefähr
ich mache das jetzt sehen im großen
bräter weil ich wie gesagt heute eine
große portion habe weil wir eben besuch
haben aber ihr könnt auch mit kleinen
pfanne nehmen oder einen kleinen
gusseisen topf das geht natürlich auch
nudelwasser auch schon mal bereit halten
[Musik]
da kann ich jetzt hier die zwiebel und
knoblauch höfen dazu geben auch schön
mit anbraten
ich war jetzt auch bewusst den fisch zum
schluss denn so kann ich noch eine
vegane fraktion für dennis mit
rausnehmen ohne fisch jetzt einfach
schön anbraten bis die zwiebeln glasig
sind biss der kürbis sowieso
karamellisiert ist und dann sehen wir
uns gleich wieder denn ich hab' gab's
nichts zu punkt nachfolgender adresse
es gebe ich hier auch die salbeiblätter
dazu die großen könnt ihr gern so ein
bisschen halbieren
wo ich auch viel saal weiterzugeben
dann auch schon mit salz und pfeffer
würzen damit der kürbis schon mal einen
schönen geschmack bekommt muss charakter
zu reiben
trotz den salbei noch mit anbraten
lassen
und ich gebe auch direkt noch die
tomaten dazu die getrockneten
nämlich hier ganz kurz alles raus
normalerweise wenn es eine kleine
portion wäre hätte ich einfach alles auf
die seite geschoben so und hier die
shrimps angebrachten dann die nudeln
dazu aber ich habe jetzt schon einige
shrimps deswegen nämlich dass kurz raus
dass ich platz habe
aber wie gesagt müsst ihr nicht wenn ihr
eine kleine portion kocht dann noch mal
ein bisschen olivenöl und schön
wir schreiben jetzt anbraten das scheint
jetzt ein herr wieder ein bisschen höher
[Musik]
die nudeln habe ich gerade abgegossen
ich hier eine vegane produktion für
dennis und hier habe ich jetzt auch
nudeln verbindet ihn ein steirischer
kürbis und ohne garnelen immer wie schön
es aussieht das sehr gesund und lecker
aus ja und da kommen jetzt die
vollkornnudeln dazu sagen wow wie will
ich das jetzt verrühren wie will das
jetzt gespannt ist er bei nudeln ich bin
da echt so ich übertreibst dann immer
gleich wenn nicht so weit kommen sechs
personen mache immer gleich ein kilo
dabei ist ja eine ports also 500 gramm
sind doch für nudeln weiß ich nicht
kenne ich keine mengenangaben ja warte
ich noch nicht ich habe eure talente
nicht nur dann immer zu über essen ich
gar nicht auf ich habe hier sind einfach
nicht auch selbst soll ich schon sagen
gezogen
bei nudeln machen ein rudel wölfe
ok also eigentlich war das rezept recht
einfach das schwierigste ist jetzt nur
diese riesenmenge so umzubringen
ich habe mich hier einfach schon mal
isolation und dann noch so von allen
kanälen
ich habe hier begonnen man kann beides
sagen ja weiß ich hab das schon mal
gegoogelt und irgendwie sagt man ich
dachte immer schlimmst wären die
größeren nicht andersrum schwimmst
werden die kleineren etappen sind noch
die kleinen karten sind die ganz gern
diese nordseekrabben sehen sie auch so
die sind ganz kleinen die sind so
richtig bleiben okay das kann dazu
shrimps und kamelle
umsatz und kürbiskerne es mir zusammen
ja komm hier schwierig wenn du bist du
nach oben hin nicht sagen vollkornnudeln
finde ich gut
ja ich hab den löffel hingelegt
italiener machen das aber so am
tellerrand archäologisch italienerin ist
der studie es nicht bis jetzt nicht und
dann schläft man den rest einfach das
ist schwierig
ich hätte mir kürbis sein dürfen aber
nicht eine ganze oder weniger nudeln
oder das mit den salbei ist eine gute
kommen wie echt gut schmeckt direkt so
als würde man tee trinkt tee mit salbei
also ich finde tatsächlich für die
kürbis menge hätte auch eine packung
nudeln gereicht hat man richtig so ein
gutes verhältnis zwischen das beschreibe
ich es euch auch im blog auf
aber jetzt habe ich hier eine
riesenmenge ich berate einfach ein
bisschen kürbis dazu an mit salbei liegt
dass hier noch mit rein und dann hab ich
was für meine gäste und ihr könnt das
rezept gerne nachmachen
schreibt mir mal ob ihr generell auch
fan von meeresfrüchten seite oder nicht
als bei mir garnelen gehen mittlerweile
alles andere tatsächlich nicht das mache
ich mir schon alles klar du hast oktopus
gegessen und hab's probiert und war gar
nicht erst mal lecker
ich kann es nur nicht wenn man die
tentakeln sieht ja ich auch noch dann
daten muss da nicht so gesehen das war
ja das war echt lecker aber wie gesagt
so zubereiten da bin ich selber noch so
ein bisschen aber dieses rezept ist
richtig lecker ihr könnt vegan machen
oder auch mit meeresfrüchten sowie ihr
gerne möchte
und das rezept findet ihr auf salehs -
block dem hänger ich finde es hier zu
schön um sie so richtig kam herrliche
das ist das bei hab ich sogar mein essen
fliegen
mehr kann man nicht sagen es war sehr
schön
mein traum ist das für dich das licht
dann wäre momentan die ich nicht mag
ich bin für dich lassen
[Musik]